the undergraduate program begins with
foundation suite of classes that are
supposed to give you perspective on all
areas of theatrical design technology
and management we're looking for
somebody with leadership potential
somebody that has their own ideas people
that are good at expressing those ideas
this is somebody that has a vocation
somebody that's had a calling to do
theatre I think a lot of the people who
are in this sort of technical theatre
realm or even directing started out as
performers being a management student in
the theatre is really facilitating
collaboration and conversations that
need to happen across various
departments bridging the gap between
that artistic mindset and the artistic
goals of everybody and the business
aspect and the structure of what needs
to happen I think that's really how both
stage managers and production managers
play an important part here at Carnegie
Mellon every titled position from
production manager all the way down to
the wrong crew all of those positions
are filled by students and it really
does prepare you for pretty much any
environment that you could find yourself
working in professionally